To accept the unknown
and to accept it in architecture,
you really need lots of courage.
So, the first thing to do,
you have to jump.
I was very attracted to these houses
which looked so deteriorated.
Everybody put me down.
But I found inside myself
a strength to build our home.
The three generation house
I built with my wife
my kids and
my parents-in-law.
There's a lot at stake if you're building
a home with your family members.
We endeavor to interfere as little
as possible with nature.
Building this place, it gave
us a sense of peace.
It saved us in a big way.
Perfection is actually
around you, you only
just have to look
and appreciate it.
This place was our dad's way
of keeping us connected.
You can't construct
anything good
if it is not with love.
I have a wonderful sense of
this is where I belong.
This is something that just developed
with us working together as a family.
It's just become,
it's become us.